hallo mein name ist willkommen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt schon keinen bock mehr
hat hier sind heute mal wieder auf der
website z 0 er unterwegs
[Musik]
pakistan kommt ich habe den jetzt mal
von einer lautstärke ausgestellt weil
der nicht das ganze sei eine website wo
einfach alle behinderten sachen
hintereinander abgespielt werden ich
kann auch random klicken und
machen wir jetzt ich habe übrigens in
adblock drin einfach weil sonst die
werbung auf dieser seite explodiert bei
youtube habe ich den aus die nächste
website kommt ist
die website nach zwölf sekunden geladen
und zwar ist das london-derby jetzt
nächste website
[Musik]
wow
diese website zeigte dem die starts der
dot org und drei würfel die die sich
drehen ich bin echt immer begeistert was
mir hier für geile sachen wirklich
angezeigt wird
nun haben wir hier tatsächlich wieder
[Musik]
ok
ein schwarzer reiter warum tue ich mir
das mal wieder an dies geht raus an alle
one direction und die justin bieber fans
und die lehne fischer ich habe die neue
boygroup des todes center das ist
wirklich die beste beugung die ich je
gesehen habe sie besteht aus so vielen
verschiedenen kulturellen
[Musik]
dingen diese boygroup trägt den namen
ich finde es auch neues wie dieses foult
jeder hinten so toll schlagzeug spielt
und dabei auch so motiviert reinschaut
ist das ein pokemon das ist einfach nur
verfolgt war sein schwarzer da rede ich
ja davor dass populisten da kommt ihr
pikachu im reifen und schriftlichen
[Musik]
boersego.de die super tragen was ist das
jetzt hier das neue anime gaming nicht
oder was
ok scheint mir wahrscheinlich zuzudecken
die winter fahre ich gesagt wissen zu
schnell
die jeden irgendwie ein bisschen zu
krass ab ist es nicht die mutter von kim
possible oder so ich muss mir mal
anschauen wie kim possible aussieht ja
das ist kim possible und ich glaube
sogar dass das gerade ihre mutter war
[Applaus]
wisst ihr wenn man auf dieser website es
gibt zum mehrere gefühls zu stellen die
man hat einer davon ist super das ist
geil einer davon ist das ist ekelhaft
und einer davon ist einfach nur so what
fragt wollt ihr mir damit sagen
denen habe ich jetzt gerade erreicht um
wieder auf die drei gefühlszustände
zurückzukommen wieder der dritte
gefühlszustand mario luigi was wollt ihr
mir damit sagen okay
[Musik]
herzlichen glückwunsch herr lass mich
wieder zum rand der verzweiflung
gebracht
[Musik]
was soll diese karte da das ist meins
das ist wie mit diesem spiel wo du so
zwei kugeln hast dann kannst du dir
sahen einander machen und die machen
dass da mit dem licht
das ist eine interessante idee mit
dieser letzten sache wenn wir jetzt das
video
[Musik]
also ich kann die damit steuern was
passiert wenn ich jetzt
[Musik]
ich bin an dieser stelle das video
werden euch diese videos gefallen die
total unsinnig sind dann zeigt man mit
einer bewertung soll ich noch mal auf z
0 er gehen oder nicht man möchte dass
kommt am ersten zwölf heraus kauft euch
davon 1000 police und die kriegt ne
tasse und kuss umsonst